bella tutti ragazzi e prenderti che solo
video sono fatti j
oggi siamo su una torre che nome di
merda è una nuova avventura horror
ragazzi spero che vi piaccia spero anche
a me perché non dovrebbe essere tanto
spaventosa vero ecco ecco già le pillole
in partenza come gli antidepressivi
perfetto che vede casinò di tempo che
non iniziamo un'avventura horror che
contro maroni già va a fuoco qualcosa
non sono stato io io io io i fiammiferi
riso usare un kayak che sono svegliato
in un'asta così mi spiegate come ci sono
finito qui prima di prima di cominciare
prima di contatto vedo di cervelli da
solo quello di sicuro non è grosso
quanto il mio cazzo cazzo sta per no
l'ho detto che oggi aveva un dentista
vero io ci avevo il dentista non lo
sapevo li mortacci mi sa che non mi
segno le cose sull'agenda ragazzi bene e
mi mi sta tagliando il pane non so lo
sento più leggero nuova bella lato
sterilizza tissimo sto posto complimenti
ai grassi la flebo e camomilla quella
non se li metti che il cazzo sta
succedendo lega cosa ci faccio qui alla
specie il cervello quindi era un
trapianto di cervello
ci ho messo del tempo infatti spero mi
abbia reso intelligente perché non ci
sono arrivato subito che mi ha buttato
in mezzo a una strada o le lattine però
va bene è un gioco un po così ragazzi e
un po accendini paranormali succede
nella vita che degli accendini provino a
tentare lo stupro ci alziamo occhiobello
posso comandarli per una volta altronde
già tutto ragazzi sono sotto effetto di
lsd crede comunque c'è un accendino vale
prendiamo questo prima di cominciare
così abbiamo qualcosa con cui far luce
perfetto non dimenticare di prendere le
tue medicine ed hai bisogno quaggiù
basso medicine per l'orgasmo da perché
non appena sentito uno a caso alla sono
già messo sotto effetto di droghe quindi
evito di prendere altre medicine grazie
di ma avanti dove siamo
sono corridoi lunghi a calcio manca
scolamiero così brutta tra l'altro
premesso è un fitto amico che lo puoi
dire a tua sorella se vuoi pure il dito
dolomiti nel culo facebook i segreti
sono fatti per essere mantenuti sai qual
è il mio segreto che la notte non riesco
a dormire da solo perché ho paura della
donna con gli orsacchiotti eppure lo
sanno tutti come è possibile questa cosa
è un capitolo porca [ __ ] è crollato
soffitto chi sa io sta facendo danza
classica di sopra non è che potete fare
il cazzo che volete ci sono io 18 che
sono un drogato comunque agazzi ancora
cosa ho preso io
si sta spendendo tutti calmi che non ho
capito come si giocano nostri comandi
non ho la più pallida idea di chi abbia
fatto sto verso basta ciò che è troppo
trendy comunque stava dicendo prima che
crollasse il soffitto siccome questo
gioco è partito che stavo dando fuoco a
qualcosa chissà che sta accendino serva
per dar fuoco alle cose quindi solo un
piromane in realtà questa è la trama del
gioco bellissimo sono riuscito a
perdermi da solo dove cazzo sono c'è ma
non c'è la prima sta cosa vado in un
corridoio c'è una cosa torna indietro e
non c'è più la cosa di prima cambiano le
cose va beh non sto capendo ma va bene
prima di andare avanti si può permesso
non dimenticare le tue pillole matelli
infilo su per il culo l'ep il no
seriamente che cazzo succede
va bene che sono interrogato di pillole
per o mio dio è una è la madonna si
sapeva prendere l'ascensore c'è una
presa della corrente possa attaccarci
l'iphone no manco quello perfetto
consentite e bruttino ragazzo gioco mi
sta mettendo un altro porca [ __ ]
[ __ ] chi è che sta ballando da tectonic
di sopra veramente così socio come
smette un'ansia pazzesca non lo sto
capendo esattamente la stessa cosa che
dicevo io quando volevano interrogarmi
lasciamo perdere sta cosa andiamo avanti
si fa presto a porta si no che apre non
si apre non so aprile sono un drogato
che non sa aprire le porte perfetto
perché a buttarlo tirare ciò ancora
questo problema nella vita reale fa
tirare la porta e spingere non azzecco
mai uno allora è pillole fila il pilot è
perfetto altre pilot è tanto con drogato
sto continuando a trovare cose ma non ho
capito il sea ecco lì sotto c'è posso
prendere qualcosa che mi mette un
attimino in sesto che mi sembra di aver
bevuto 12 bottiglie di vodka non sa
perché after sbronza ragazzi una notte
da [ __ ] è una roba normale succede
devo andare di qua no non devo andare di
qua te con detto tornare a casa grazie
dite che funzionano l'orologio allora
sono le tre sì credo beh ragazzi non so
se funzionava se funziona sono in
ritardo marcio quindi fatemi andare
avanti cioè le porte sono le un l'unica
cosa veramente che salvo list o posto di
merda
fa tutto schifo tranne questo successo
sia lodato il cielo posso farmi una
doccia per lei bella pulita
senti puoi vomitare ti prego fai
qualcosa che mi sembra in coma etilico
non posso vomitare ma ok
quanti mi servirebbe un gps
possibilmente di qui l'atto del cibo in
scatola perfetto sono fottutamente salvo
avessi trovato prima ragazzi il cibo in
scatola
la risposta a tutti i dilemmi del mondo
proprio e non si apre un pene prima
davanti a caso ci sono materassi sul
muro cos'è
oh mio dio una radio anni 40 c'è david
guetta ragazzi
non si può mettere della musica che li
che tragico tuo 26 permessa lurida tazza
di merda muoverti da solo io posso
portare dietro questa tassa che mi
dispiace lasciarlo a qui se volevi
venire come me lo chiede vi e basta non
c'è bisogno di fare così ok sai
maleducazione
io mò ti lascio lì stronza limite se una
tazza di merda deve farmi venire i colpi
per niente c'è una roba indecente che ci
sono già stato gatto rai e ci sono cosa
è successo mi chiami è volato bene le
luci che si accendono non sono proprio
belle
l'ho scoperto adesso orca [ __ ] sono
pagati ma non aspettavo luridi non aver
capito chi è che ha acceso la luce ma
[ __ ] non fatelo mai più nella vita
ma se qualcuno in questo gioco sono
completamente das no perché raramente
anzi meglio in certi casi è stata
ovviamente non si apre ma ci mancherebbe
altro ma video ho preso la videocassetta
cosa dove un muro a caso che cosa ci fa
un muro di ma [ __ ] anche tu dai ma
dai
porca [ __ ] [ __ ] ragazzi io in questa
porta non ci vado grazie allora una no
no non ascoltati se esce qualcosa
madonna gli schiaffi mano ma giura
scendo malissimo ci ha scritto prendi le
pillole ma quali cazzo di pillole non ho
pillole da temi della madonna sto messo
sversi simo questi sono facciola i
facciola mangiami facciolo al posto
delle pillole che cazzo via dic ma
velocissimo guarda cori come una lepre
lurido non ci posso che ma come che so
che ogni volta che trovo salve ma senta
lei ben tratto nel muro entrato nel muro
in piazza a quello di harry potter
adesso ci provo anch'io ragazzi chiudete
gli occhi vi giuro che saremo dall'altra
parte ve lo giuro a di 3 1 2 3
chiudeteli
riapriteli adesso vi giuro che siamo
passati attraverso il muro ve lo giuro
ragazzi è stato bellissimo niente volevo
dirvi che ho detto io c'ero una cassetta
adesso posso usarla si si va verso una
classe a cazzo stand by
si sono leggermente bédard triplo
ragazzi vi spiego vi faccio una lezione
proprio pratica pratica questi sono gli
effetti del gene mescolato con vodka
mescolato con rum tutto mix questo che
succede questo cos'è star o mio dio con
film ci mettiamo è ma non c'è manco la
sedia si cela sedia pro mancano i pop
corn e c'è la tazzina lì che mi sta
guardando male quindi non posso
godermelo ma io so quale questo posto ci
ero passato
ciao bella donna non ascolta vi è andata
via succede così le donne vanno e
vengono
la partita c'è un topo di le disegnato
tuzi è molto bello lo tengo come una
lettera d'amore grazie
c'è chi manda lettere d'amore c'è chi
disegna i topi io preferisco i topi è
una cosa personale comunque ragazzi a
parte questo ho messo la cassetta quindi
devo tornare nel punto di prima era la
pa pa pa pa pa pa pa
tua madre che mi attraversa il testicolo
destro ma [ __ ] come ti sei
permesso mai nella vita di attraversare
milano come ci sono persone che mi
camminano addosso all'improvviso piegate
vela questa vi prego gioco ragazzi la
cosa più strana che io abbia mai giocato
in tutta la mia vita raga ve lo giuro è
stranissimo permesso si chiama hector la
marca della giacca i maglioni non fate
videogiochi non siete capaci
ok sì l'ho ritrovato ragazzi ho trovato
era qui il tipo il tipo della cassetta
d'acqua quindi che cosa dovrei fare qui
ecco la veduta c'è la tele calcia mamma
ciao ciao grande fratello noel cazzo
proprio così
ma chi c'era arrivato che c'erano che
cos'è una torcia ti ringrazio gesù
madonna mia il ragazzo più contento
della storia veramente fatemi usare come
si usa f se non cazzo ma ora grazie ho
trovato la torcia però non ho
assolutamente capito come si equipaggia
quindi infilerò da qualche parte forse
sapete anche dove però non so come
usarla cosa ho messo si apre ti apre di
[ __ ] non sia aperta dai dai che ho
messo qualcosa ho visto apri stronzo
spingi spingi spingi amaci volato si
tirava si tirava la forte [ __ ] [ __ ]
cioè io io veramente ciò dei problemi a
livello di spingere tirare le cose c'è
veramente assurdo è una roba veramente
ragazzi è il ridicolo e assumano potete
scrivere tira spinge a secondo lei
perché sono mica mi faccia di problemi
incredibili o mi prendete per il culo
porca [ __ ] ragazzi
madonna che brutta dovrebbe essere senti
ha fatto così ma [ __ ] questo che
questo non me l'aspettavo
giuro muri di bastard che i coriandoli i
coriandoli il coriandolo no non l'avevo
che c'è un buco in fondo lega ragazzi
quindi ragazzi il primo episodio di
hector finisce qui continuerò poi nel
prossimo spero che vi piace come gioco
perché a parte essere drogati e carino
sto scherzando ma vabbè se non ci
fossero rispondenti sarebbe carino ma ce
li hanno messi quindi vabbè comunque
ragazzi concluso mio episodio spero che
mi è dispiaciuto ma senza stato di 300
secondi vi piace anche voglia di
facebook e come noi video tratto nella
descrizione se voleste discrete vi però
mi piace che mettete i miei capelli
torneranno a posto ma non so se ci
riusciremo
e certo che non c'è più
non penso l'ho perso e non chiudono mai
vi do siamo così
cos'è questa
mela ragazzi